[موسيقى]
أنا دانا سانتس مدرب للتنفس والتنقل
والجسد في الرياضات الاحترافية
يقدم المشي الكثير من الفوائد ولكن من
المهم حقًا الانتباه إلى
هذا التوازن في أحد الجانبين والآخر
لبعض المشكلات الشائعة التي أراها
عندما يكون الناس  المشي هو عندما
يحملون حقيبة يحملونها فقط على
الجانب المهيمن ، سنمشي كلابنا
ممسكين المقود في جانب واحد حتى لو
كنا نمسك بأيدينا أو نمسك بهاتفنا
الذي سيبدأ في العبث حقًا
مع الجزء العلوي لدينا  أجسام لا يجب أن
تفكر فيها كثيرًا ولكنك تريد بالتأكيد
التأكد من أن هناك تأرجحًا للذراع
يتناوب بشكل متبادل مما يبدو
معقدًا للغاية ولكن ما يعنيه حقًا هو
فقط عندما يقوم جانب واحد من الجسم
بعمل شيء ما على الجانب الآخر  عند القيام
بالآخر في نمط ينتهي بنا الأمر
بمقاطعة هذا النمط عن غير قصد
إذا كنا نعتمد على الجانب المهيمن لدينا
في كل ما نقوم به خاصة عندما
نحمل أي نوع من الوزن ، لذلك إذا كان
عليك حمل حقيبة وكان لدينا جميعًا
لحمل الحقائب في وقت أو آخر ، ثم
تأكد من أنك لا تحملها دائمًا
على نفس الجانب
أثناء السير ، فهذا يمنحنا
فرصة رائعة لمجرد ضبط
ما يقوله لنا أجسامنا لا
تتجاهله  إذا كان لديك زوج من الأحذية
كنت ترتديه لفترة من الوقت ، تحقق
من نعل حذائك ، فقد ترى
المزيد من ارتداء حذاء أكثر من
الآخر لأن لديك جانبًا
تخطو عليه بثقل مما يعني
أنك الآن "  سوف نضع مزيدًا من الضغط على تلك
الركبة ، وربما يكون المزيد من الضغط على تلك الركبة بمجرد
أن ترى أنه الآن عندما تخرج
وتمشي ، يمكنك البدء في إدراك
المزيد قليلاً عما يحدث مع توزيع الوزن
في قدمي
عندما أرى اختلالات في التوازن.  تريد أن يبدأ الأشخاص في
أداء ما يسمى بالتمارين الأحادية الجانب ،
وهي تمارين
تأخذك على ساق واحدة مثل نوع
من التمارين التي تعتمد على مفصل الورك والتي ستترجم إلى
تمشية أفضل
[موسيقى]